la función fx esta gráfica da encuentra
este de 4 así que aquí tenemos la
gráfica que esencialmente es una
representación visual de una función y
la forma en la que funciona esto es que
cuando quiero encontrar el valor que
toma la función en un valor dado por
ejemplo aquí lo que hago es subir sobre
ese punto hasta la gráfica y luego ver
la altura que tiene ese punto y eso me
dirá el valor que toma la función así
que para encontrar efe 4 simplemente me
muevo en mi eje horizontal en mi eje x
al 4 subo la gráfica llegó a este punto
y me fijo en su altura en su core de
nadie que es 8 así que en este caso f 4
es 8
muy bien hagamos otro la función fx está
definida como fx igual a 2 x 3 encuentra
el valor de f 7 en este caso tengo la
función definida como este polinomio lo
único que tengo que hacer es sustituir
por 7 en todos los lugares donde
aparezca x así que f 7 sería igual a 2
por 7 menos 3 2 por 7 es 14 - 3 es 11
hagamos un último
la función f x está definida como f x es
igual a 5 x 3 encuentra el valor de f de
1 nuevamente simplemente cambio todas
las x que aparecen en esta expresión en
la definición de fx x 1 entonces obtengo
cinco por uno menos 35 por 15 32
y estamos en lo correcto espero que
ustedes pueden hacer los demás
ejercicios